[Music]
good afternoon ladies gentlemen welcome
aboard captain speaking much
anticipating on-time arrival in the
scenario where there's a flight
cancellation or some other off-schedule
operation we've had a system where we
find new seats and flights availability
for those customers but I think
oftentimes customers didn't necessarily
know that that was the best option for
them what we wanted to do was create a
system where they could actually see
alternate options the goal was to
facilitate a better experience for our
customers on how to get to their
destination in an automated fashion on
the channel of their choice so we
partnered with IBM and specifically IBM
cloud platform to adopt their garage
method pair programming test-driven
development the original timeline was
actually over a year so American
approached IBM and asked us if there was
any way we could help them shorten that
timeline from the time that we started
development on dynamic rebooking until
the time that we actually had customers
using it was about four and a half
months we were kind of cautious to
release this product we rolled it out to
a limited number of stations across all
the channels and it really went
flawlessly
we are now crossing into a zone of
turbulence please keep your seatbelt
fastened
in our business hurricanes storms are
the natural events impact our customers
on fairly regular basis what happened
and this is true story
the Hurricanes hit and nobody said this
is ridiculous our customers were being
impacted by the Hurricanes immediately
why are we mitigating risk of a
traditional rollout when we have the
power of the clouds and this is exactly
the scenario that our customers need
this capability we made the decision as
a team that the tool needed to be turned
on and especially in the hardest hit
areas so we did having the confidence to
just flip the switch really came out of
the whole project from the beginning
this was a unique opportunity for us
really to embed the business side right
in with the technology team one of our
expectations when we were moving to the
IBM cloud was the scale and the hyper
scale of cloud should relieve our normal
concerns around infrastructure when we
roll out an application globally so when
the hurricanes hit we put that to a test
and our confidence was there and the
application worked flawlessly I think
people will now realize that these kind
of activities and integration are much
easier when we can use cloud technology
and especially micro services we can
break problems into much smaller
problems and those get much easier to
wrap your head around and develop this
is the technology that we need to be
adopting now in order to keep pace with
our customer expectations
you